[Applause]  join the tea ja Moran  so Moran takes it and draws it Marie  answers the triple and runnin behind  Moran gals out because seven-point lead  into the half Brendon Bailey  [Applause]  jabberin look at his footwork to create  separation just too quick with the ball  in his hands two tournaments two leading  schools and what a great backdoor cut oh  boy at the rim wow we were talking to  mark he does such a great job of just  extending the double-team and then with  his do they make their teammates better  would you answer that with a coming  right here Carter a rant on Bailey top  pick close it  the night sing on the king with a little  finger roll